und jetzt das heute journal mit einer
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend ihnen einen
fußball deutschland feiert heute mit
frankfurt und frankfurt feiert sowieso
die eintracht hat den pokal in der
europa league und sie ist gemeinsam mit
ihm jetzt im moment wieder zu hause
angekommen das sind live-bilder vom
frankfurter römer ein mehr von emotionen
jetzt im moment in diesem moment in dem
sich die mannschaft auf den balkon ihren
fans zeigt die stundenlang warten
mussten in frankfurt in brütender hitze
und durch gewitterregen hindurch wir
gehen gleich live auf dem frankfurter
römer ein europapokal sieg ist
tausendmal besser als sex sagt eintracht
präsident peter fischer und liefert
folgende erklärung gleich hinterher weil
diese pokale gibt es verdammt verdammt
selten das stimmt es sind exakt 42 jahre
nach dem eintrag triumph im uefa cup
1980 es ist ein sportlicher und
finanzieller quantensprung für den
traditionsverein und er bringt der
bundesliga neues internationales renomee
kurz das war ein fußball fest dass auch
nicht hessen begeistert peter theißen
zdf frankfurt
es ist der magische moment dem fußball
frankfurt so lange entgegengefiebert hat
der pokal ist zurück nach 42 jahren
kapitän und trainer tragen ihn ins
frankfurter rathaus brück klappt als
raphael poirée den entscheidenden
elfmeter zum titelgewinn versenkt da
brechen alle dämme in siviglia bei der
mannschaft und bei den 50.000 feinen
fans beim public viewing im frankfurter
waldstadion
in der nacht verwandeln die fans die
frankfurter innenstadt in eine einzige
feier meile und so mancher blieb die
ganze nacht auf und sichert sich heute
morgen auf dem römerberg schon seinen
platz für den empfang der europapokal
helden
gut herzen sagt aber wir haben es gewagt
deswegen sowie radierungen
von der ersten bis zur letzten minute
der hammer das beste was ich hier erlebt
habe ja wirklich wir haben den
europapokal um viertel vor sechs dann
landet der europa league sieger auf dem
frankfurter flughafen trainer und
kapitän mit dem 15 kilo schweren pokal
im autokorso geht es nur ganz langsam
richtung stadtmitte denn immer wieder
hallten begeisterte fans den konvoi auf
auch ein heftiger regenguss
zwischendurch tut der stimmung auf dem
römerberg keinen abbruch
[Applaus]
12 tausend kehlen singen und schreien
alleine auf dem römerberg um die wette
wie viele fans insgesamt in der stadt
sind keiner weiß es genau
100 oder 200 tausend sie wirbeln den
zeitplan des triumphzuges jedenfalls
ordentlich durcheinander
doch das scheint niemanden wirklich zu
stören
und dann zeigen sie sich und dem pokal
endlich den seit stunden wartenden fans
die party in frankfurt sie hat gerade
erst begonnen
wir sind alle helden ohne die zuschauer
hätten wir das nicht geschafft wir alle
sind das sagt torhüter kevin trapp und
auch das ist wahr markus wolsiffer ist
am frankfurter römer für uns in life
markus wir alle sind dass das ist jetzt
im moment zu spüren oder
[Applaus]
absolut das ist eine gemeinschaft die
man sie in der fußball deutschland in
europa kaum kennt tausende fans ihres
und 13.000 sein wir dürfen gar nicht
rein und um 21 35 war es soweit da
betrat die mannschaft den balkon und
dieser ohrenbetäubende lärm hat sich
noch einmal intensiviert gestern im
stadion waren wir da war es schon
richtig laut aber dieser moment nach 42
jahren hat die eintracht celle so
beflügelt dass es heute wirklich noch
die ganze nacht dauern wird wir sind
gespannt wollen sie durchhalten vorhin
war noch schlechtes wetter hat geregnet
es hat gewittert sind alle durchgehalten
für diese mannschaft auf diesem balkon
markus wollen sie verleihe frankfurter
römer ganz herzlichen dank und viel spaß
noch in dieser weiteren durchwachten
nacht in frankfurt wir freuen uns alle
mit euch über den europapokalsieg so hat
der bundeskanzler der eintracht
gratuliert mehr relevanz dürfte das
haben was olaf scholz heute im bundestag
gesagt hat wir lassen niemanden allein
das kann man als versprechen nehmen vor
allem für menschen mit geringem
einkommen der staat werde die steigenden
preise im zuge des ukraine krieges
abfedern konkrete neue vorhaben dazu
kündigte er nicht an der krieg war heute
thema einer regierungserklärung des
kanzlers einer debatte im großen
plenarsaal
er war auch thema in den räumen des
parlaments die nicht im
scheinwerferlicht stehen und gerade dort
ganz besonders eindrücklich wie andreas
künast jetzt zeigt ich bin schon
ich kann ihnen sagen
ungefähr
75 tage im krankenhaus hannah polanska
will wieder gehen will wieder leben und
sie will ihre geschichte erzählen wie
sie zu fliehen versuchten ausputzer sie
ihr mann und der hund voller angst und
voller hoffnung auf das entscheidende
bisschen glück
und einige von diesen autos wurden
beschlossen einige nicht so das war wie
im lotto spielen
ziemlich schräg nicht
aus ihrem krankenzimmer ist hanna in
raum 51 14 des bundestags geschaltet sie
berichtet per zoom konferenz wie die
russen ihr auto beschossen anton war
sofort tot ihr ungeborenes kind einen
jungen hat sie später verloren die
deutsch ukrainische parlamentarier
gruppe fragt ob hanna eine botschaft hat
eine botschaft an deutschland die
antwort ist nicht überraschend ich bin
keine phase auch in dieser hinsicht
bestimmt ich bin einfach lehrerin
für das ende des krieges sind missionen
und ausrüstung ausschließlich wichtig
dass die bundesregierung aus der ukraine
um waffen gebeten wird ist nicht
unumstritten wird fünf stunden früher
fünf stockwerke tiefer der deutsche
kanzler sagen olaf scholz wird von
diskussionen im wahlkreis sprechen von
briefen von bürgern denen die
unterstützung zu weit geht
ich will daher eines ganz deutlich sagen
einem brutal angegriffen land bei der
verteidigung zu helfen darin liegt keine
eskalation
scholz hat recht sagt der
oppositionsführer nur was er sage passe
nicht zu dem was er tut der
bundeskanzler treibe ein doppeltes spiel
die wahrheit ist doch dass aus
deutschland in den letzten wochen so gut
wie nichts an waffen geliefert worden
ist wir wissen es doch wir können doch
die dokumente einsehen es wird praktisch
nichts geliefert die hauptverantwortung
tragen die verteidigungsministerin deren
entlassung märz fordert während für die
union scholz und seine spd die ukraine
zu wenig unterstützen ist es der linken
und der afd zu viel
wer nach kia fährt muss auch nach moskau
fahren um gesprächsfaden wieder
aufzunehmen beschreiten sie bitte den
weg der vernunft vielen herzlichen dank
gespräche mit moskau verhandlungen mit
dem regime und wladimir putin für hanna
polonski ist der gedanke unerträglich
mein mann ist tot und nicht nur mein
also viele menschen dort und für diese
verbrechen
sollte russland zu rechnen schreibt
jetzt darin werden anna polanska will
wieder leben will wieder auf eigenen
beinen stehen genau wie ihr land auf
hilfe werden beide noch lange angewiesen
sein
die côte d'azur liegt ziemlich weit weg
von der ukraine gefühlt nochmal viel
weiter wenn in cannes die stars und
sternchen des kinos mit champagner
austern und rotem teppich beschäftigt
sind und dennoch kommt das wichtigste
filmfestival der welt nicht vorbei am
krieg im osten europas auch deshalb weil
dort ukrainische und russische filme
aufeinandertreffen ukrainische und
russische filmemacher kann wird geradezu
gezwungen eine diskussion zu führen der
wir uns alle stellen müssen über krieg
und kultur boykott und toleranz sabine
schulz
auch in cannes ist putins angriffskrieg
präsent vier ukrainische filme werden
gezeigt doch gleich zu beginn sorgt ein
russischer film für streit zumindest
seine anwesenheit kiril serebrennikow
international gefeierter film und
opernregisseur aus russland ein
freigeist der im eigenen land unter
beschuss steht von putins regime mit
absurden klagen aus dem verkehr gezogen
verhaftet prozesse jahrelang hausarrest
preise verbot seine kann premieren
wurden zu protestaktionen dabei sein
konnte er nie
anfang des jahres konnte er überraschend
endlich sein land verlassen lebt seitdem
in berlin und ist zum ersten mal in
cannes nicht alle freuen sich darüber
[Musik]
wir fordern das festival auf die
kulturelle zusammenarbeit mit russland
einzustellen mit allen russischen
künstlern und filmemachern bis russland
sich vom gebiet der ukraine zurück zieht
und für die kriegsverbrechen
verantwortlich gemacht wird das heißt
keine vorführung von russischen firmen
und keine russische filmemacher
man hört sie immer öfter die forderung
nach dem kultur boykott doch treffe sie
auch kritische stimmen die selbst unter
putins repressalien leiden
das festival hat eine klare haltung
offizielle regierungstreue vertreter
russlands sind nicht zugelassen
doch das gilt nicht für russische
künstler und journalisten die das land
verlassen haben
kiril serebrennikow ist der ansicht wenn
er russland nicht verlassen hätte hätte
er sich zum komplizen dieses krieges
gemacht
dialog oder pauschale bestrafung es sind
fragen wie diese die in kahn diskutiert
werden
mein film ist ein unabhängiger
russischer film ohne geld von der
regierung alle die diesen film gemacht
haben sind vehement gegen den krieg
jeder film jede form von kunst oder
theaterproduktion ist ein statement zum
wert des lebens und ist das gegenteil
von diesem krieg
ein krieg der auch hinkam präsent ist
der dokumentarfilm mario police 2 zeigt
die zerstörung und das leid der menschen
in mario pohl der filmemacher mantas
creditsuisse wo der anfang april bei den
dreharbeiten von der russischen armee
getötet
seine verlobte die ukrainerin hanna
billa pro war hat das material gesichert
und den film geschnitten
wir wollen sein vermächtnis und sein
leben als filmemacher ehren ein
bewegender moment eine etwas andere
premiere in cannes wo sich das
weltgeschehen spielten
nicht nur beim film läuft die diskussion
macht es sinn wenn musik festivals jetzt
tschaikowsky vom spielplan nehmen das
thema wird uns weiter beschäftigen
erstmal heute hier an diesem tag hanna
jetzt und die erste nachrichtenübersicht
ganz genau und die beginnt mit einer
nachricht aus dem hohen norden
deutschlands in schleswig holstein ist
eine weiterführung des jamaika
bündnisses vom tisch das ist das
ergebnis eines ersten gemeinsamen
sondierungsgesprächs von cdu grünen und
fdp die grünen teilten mit dass sie die
gespräche beendet hätten da ist keine
gemeinsame basis für eine koalition gebe
in der einer der partner nicht gebraucht
werde jamaica war die erklärte wunsch
koalition von ministerpräsident günther
und das obwohl die cdu auch allein mit
fdp oder mit grünen eine
regierungsmehrheit hätte
nachdem finnland und schweden ihre
beitritts anträge zur nato eingereicht
haben ist jetzt das bündnis am zug doch
noch immer stemmt sich die türkei gegen
eine aufnahme
nato-generalsekretär ian stoltenberg
sagte dass die mitglieder auf die
bedenken ankaras eingehen würden und
dass er eine schnelle entscheidung
erwartet
us-präsident beiden empfing heute
schwedens ministerpräsidentin und den
finnischen präsidenten in washington
beiden ländern sagte er seine
unterstützung für die aufnahme zu
um sehr viel geld für die ukraine ging
es heute beim g7-finanzministertreffen
in königswinter bei bonn 15 milliarden
euro benötigt das land in den kommenden
drei monaten um die ausgaben im
staatshaushalt decken zu können
deutschland will sich mit einer
milliarde euro beteiligen die usa werden
voraussichtlich etwa 7,5 milliarden
beisteuern
zudem hat der us senat vor wenigen
stunden einem weiteren hilfspaket für
die ukraine zugestimmt und so 40
milliarden us dollar auf den weg
gebracht
gerhard schröder werden teile seiner
sonderrechte als früherer bundeskanzler
entzogen das hat heute der
haushaltsausschuss des bundestags
entschieden davon ist schröders büro
betroffenen genauso wie seine
mitarbeiter begründet wird der schritt
damit dass schröder keine verpflichtung
mehr aus seinem ehemaligen amt wahrnehme
gleichzeitig stimmte das eu parlament
dafür den altkanzler wegen seiner
verbindungen zur russischen
staatskonzernen auf die eu
sanktionsliste zu setzen sollte dies
tatsächlich geschehen könnte die eu das
vermögen schröders einfrieren
der bundestag will in einer sitzung bis
nach mitternacht zahlreiche gesetze
verabschieden aktuell geht es um das 9
euro ticket das ab dem ersten juni
gelten soll bereits beschlossen ist die
weitreichende streichung von sanktionen
für hartz 4 empfänger wobei wiederholten
melde verstößen können leistungen
gekürzt werden zudem hat das parlament
entlastungen wegen der korona pandemie
verlängert so kann auch dieses jahr bei
der steuer die home office pauschale
geltend gemacht werden für pflegekräfte
hat der bundestag einen bonus von bis zu
2500 euro beschlossen
an einer schule in bremerhaven sind am
morgen schüsse gefallen dabei ist eine
frau lebensgefährlich verletzt worden
ein 21-jähriger mann war gegen 9 uhr 15
während der abitur nach prüfung mit
einer armbrust und einer
schreckschusspistole in das gymnasium
eingedrungen der mutmaßliche täter
konnte festgenommen werden über die
hintergründe der tat ist laut polizei
bisher noch nichts bekannt
bislang schweigt der festgenommene
blitze donner dunkler himmel das ist die
situation heute abend in teilen
deutschlands gerade im westen am
nachmittag gab es bereits warnungen des
deutschen wetterdienstes für nordrhein
westfalen vor schweren gewittern und
heftigen starkregen
während die allermeisten von uns dann
alarmiert nach oben schauen und hoffen
es werde vorbei gehen sind solche
warnungen allein bereits für die
menschen im aartal etwas ganz anderes
sie wissen was passiert wenn es nicht
vorbeigeht wenn menschen deshalb sterben
und existenzen vernichtet werden sie
haben das erlebt und es ist nicht mal
ein jahr her julia schröter
stoßstange an stoßstange
seit 7 uhr stehen sie schlange vor dem
betriebshof in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler
das begehrte gut sandsäcke die männer
vom ordnungsamt die aufpassen sind über
den andrang nicht überrascht und nach
der schadenslage die firma war ist
natürlich klar dass die bevölkerung
bisschen angst du bist ein sensibler
alle sind und dass dann schon klar dass
wir einen kombi fahren wollen auf dem
betriebshof angekommen geht alles wie am
schnürchen und nach dem drive im prinzip
zuerst werden die personalien
aufgenommen damit niemand mehrmals
abholt dann kofferraum auf sandsäcke
rein jeder privathaushalt bekommt zehn
gewerbetreibende 30 klappe zu fertig
abgefüllt werden die säcke ein paar
meter weiter zehn kilo kommenden jeden
tag unermüdlich verknotet von
bauhofmitarbeitern und freiwilligen vom
helfer shuttle
auch sascha spessart und jens hillmann
haben sandsäcke geholt auch sie sind
freiwillige helfer die seit monaten im
aartal unterstützen besonders unter ihre
fittiche genommen haben sie eine
kneipenwirtin die in der flut
vergangenen juli schwer gelitten hat
die junge frau ist die besitzerin des
ladens die ist schon seit zwei tagen fix
und fertig weil es montag hier auch
nicht so günstig gelaufen ist die ganze
straße aber voll mit wasser hier waren
mehrere löschzüge die ausgepumpt haben
jetzt reden möchte sie nicht zu
schmerzlich immerhin das jetzt sandsäcke
im haus sind ist eine kleine beruhigung
wir stellen die heute abend oder heute
nachmittag hier vor den zwei türen damit
auf jeden fall da kein was haben wir
rein kommt und wir haben hier vorne
einen schacht der zum keller geht da kam
extrem viel regen in letzter zeit rein
und dadurch läuft der keller lagen
wieder voll und das wollen wir einfach
umgehen damit größten für die womöglich
nächste flut dabei sind die
traumatischen erinnerungen an den
vergangenen sommer bei den betroffenen
noch so präsent
es gibt situationen die ich von
betroffenen erzählt bekommen haben die
frau mit ihrem auto in die waschstraße
reihen der magischen panikattacken uhr
in der waschstraße schon ja dann könnt
ihr euch vorstellen wie es ist wenn sie
jetzt hier wieder wasser auf der straße
steht dann sieht das auch ein bisschen
ganz anders aus weil ich glaube hier
schläft keiner diese nacht holt zurück
zum betriebshof allein gestern haben sie
hier 4000 sandsäcke ausgegeben heute
dürften es mindestens genauso viele sein
es ist wenig was man selber tun kann
aber immer noch besser als einfach nur
hilflos auf das unwetter zu warten
und heute abend wieder regen im aartal
der bürgermeister von bad neuenahr
ahrweiler hat seine bürger gewarnt vor
dem was kommen könnte guido orthen sagt
wir werden gemeinsam auch dieses
starkregen ereignis meistern aber und
das weiß ich sehr gut wir fühlen anders
dabei die aktuelle wetterlage gleich
nach dieser sendung bei uns hier
ausführlich im zdf
das höchste deutsche gericht hat heute
eine abwägung getroffen so wie es immer
abwägen muss wenn grundrechte
beeinträchtigt sind es ging heute um die
grundrechte von allen die im
gesundheitsbereich und in der pflege
arbeiten ist die korona impfpflicht für
sie rechtens das verfassungsgericht sagt
ja damit dürfte ein langer bitterer
streit erst mal zu ende sein zumindest
juristisch und auch ganz praktisch ist
die lage rund um die impfpflicht für das
pflegepersonal deutlich entspannter als
von vielen befürchtet zeigt christian
von rechenberg
das massieren tut gut das lenkt frau
pauli ab von ihrem sorgen frau pauli das
ist die sozialbetreuerin sie hat als
eine der ersten in deutschland post vom
gesundheitsamt bekommen soll innerhalb
14 tagen nachweisen dass sie geimpft
oder genesen ist sonst droht bußgeld
2500 euro
frau pauli hat aber auch angst vor dem
impfstoff eine schwierige situation denn
sie hat im pflegeheim st hedwig in
wittenburg dauernd engen kontakt zu
alten und menschen mit vorerkrankungen
für die kann kowitz schnell
lebensbedrohlich werden impfungen wirken
bei ihnen weniger gut zugleich sind sie
auf die nähe anderer angewiesen
der staat muss die ergo besonders
schützen stellt das
bundesverfassungsgericht heute klar dem
hohen gesundheitsrisiko von geschwächten
menschen stehe ein deutlich geringeres
imf risiko der pflegenden gegenüber lob
vom gesundheitsminister ich hatte mit
diesem ergebnis gerechnet
ich möchte aber die gelegenheit nutzen
all den einrichtungen zu danken die
diese impfpflicht umgesetzt haben das
war eine großartige leistung
dabei haben die einrichtungen noch gar
nicht so viel umgesetzt bisher eher ans
personal appelliert offenbar es
tatsächlich nur ein geringer teil der
pflegenden in deutschland ohne impfung
in schleswig-holstein ergab eine zdf
stichprobe nur drei prozent in
nordrhein- westfalen knapp zehn prozent
nur sachsen fällt mit mehr als 30 aus
der reihe als die impfpflicht für
pflegende ende letzten jahres gesetz
wurde befürchteten viele den pflege
kollaps ausfälle gab es auch aber
weniger als gedacht hier werden
bußgelder verhängen momentan es werden
noch keine berufsverbote tatsächlich
adressiert das können wir uns auch
tatsächlich gar nicht leisten weil es
weil wir sonst in versorgungsengpässe
rutschen ich denke das weiß der
gesetzgeber tatsächlich prüft das
gesundheitsamt jeden gemeldeten
einzelfall und das kann dauern so lange
kennt liegende weiterarbeiten sich
impfen lassen oder mit dem arbeitgeber
nach auswegen suchen andere abteilung
oder mehr schutzkleidung
bei frau pauli ist all das
schwierig das geht nicht dass einer der
in der pflege beschäftigt ist kein
kontakt zu den tisch legen genau das
kann nicht funktionieren
und ich kann ihm also keine andere
arbeiten arbeiten anbieten würde der
leiter aber gerne denn fachkräfte wie
frau pauli sind wert wollen er hat sorge
sie zu verlieren
ich arbeite und das mit leib und seele
tue und
frau pauli hat erstmal widerspruch
eingelegt ein langes verfahren könnte
ihr und der einrichtung helfen ende des
jahres läuft die impfpflicht nämlich aus
und um eine andere wichtige berufsgruppe
geht es jetzt bei diana christian es
waren ca tarifverhandlungen bei denen es
um die zukunft von 330.000 beschäftigten
in kitas und sozialen einrichtungen ging
am ende steht jetzt eine einigung die
gewerkschaft verdi zeigte sich auch
zufrieden damit allerdings valerie
haller es gibt ein nicht ganz
unwichtiges aber ja ein wichtiges ziel
für die beschäftigten ist ja die
entlastung des fordern die
gewerkschaften schon seit jahren jetzt
sollen die beschäftigten tatsächlich
mehr freie zeit bekommen aber
grundsätzlich fehlt personal und
irgendjemand muss ja die arbeit machen
wenn mitarbeiter mehr freizeit haben
also da wird man sehen müssen ob die
neuen zusagen reichen um den job
attraktiver zu machen wechselwillige zu
halten und auch neue kräfte anzuziehen
jetzt aber dürfen sich erzieher in
kommunalen kitas und beschäftigte in
sozialen berufen erstmal auf mehr geld
und freizeit freuen die einigung im
tarifstreit sieht zwei zusätzliche freie
tage und zwei weitere optionale tage
gegen freiwillige gehaltseinbußen vor ab
juli sollen erzieher monatlich 130 euro
und sozialarbeiter 180 mehr bekommen
zudem soll berufserfahrung künftig auch
stärker honoriert werden die gehälter
steigen also schneller als bisher werden
den allgemeinen stufen im öffentlichen
dienst angepasst verdi will seine
mitglieder bis juni noch über die
tarifeinigung
stimmen lassen aber es gilt schon als
sehr wahrscheinlich dass der vertrag
angenommen wird und die nächsten
tarifverhandlungen im öffentlichen
dienst die stehen schon im januar an die
kommunalen beschäftigten im sozial und
erziehungsdienst können dann auf weitere
verbesserungen hoffen danke valerie nach
frankfurt
die führungsetagen großer deutscher
unternehmen sind noch immer eine
männerdomäne das zeigt eine aktuelle
studie der bat-stiftung dabei schneiden
familienunternehmen besonders schlecht
ab in den geschäftsführungen der 100
größten familiengeführten firmen lag der
frauenanteil bei 8,3 prozent bei den dax
konzernen sind ist doppelt so viele
nämlich 14,3 prozent albright stiftungen
würden börsenunternehmen bei der
nachbesetzung von stellen systematisch
frauen rekrutieren familienunternehmen
dagegen nicht
es gibt eine amtliche unwetterwarnung
des deutschen wetterdienstes vor
verbreiteten starken teils schweren
gewittern
niko kovac kehrt zurück in die
bundesliga und wird neuer trainer des
vfl wolfsburg
laut medienberichten übernimmt er die
funktion mit sofortiger wirkung und
folgt auch florian kufeld der am sonntag
überraschend entlassen worden war kovac
war zuletzt trainer beim as monaco zuvor
gelang ihm als chefcoach beim fc bayern
2009 10 der gewinn des doubles aus
meisterschaft und dfb-pokal
evangelos oder desserts papathanassiou
ist tot der name allein wird ihnen
möglicherweise wenig sagen aber wenn sie
gleich hören was er geschaffen hat ein
zeitloser melodie dann ist alles klar
vangelis der mann aus athen war ein
pionier elektronischer musik er wurde
mit filmhits weltberühmt hat einen oscar
gewonnen hier für dieses chariots of
fire
hat für das ballett komponiert für
fußball weltmeisterschaften und
olympische spiele meine musik versucht
nicht emotionen hervorzurufen wie freude
oder schmerz ich arbeite für den moment
um ein bild zu begleiten
[Musik]
tausende bilder gehen uns dabei durch
den kopf und dazu jetzt die trauer um
einen der nie viel aufhebens um seine
person wollte er lebte in der musik
vangelis wurde 79 jahre alt
das war unsere welt an diesem donnerstag
ich lege ihnen die kollegen maybrit
illner ans herz jetzt gleich krieg in
der ukraine was will der westen
erreichen außerdem empfehlen wir ihnen
unser heute-journal update gegen 0.30
mit masern charakter mehr von uns allen
hier im heute journal ein angenehm
[Musik]
ja guten abend zum wetter heute abend es
ist noch einiges los im land heute gab
es ja den ersten teil einer schwer
gewitter lage eine richtig lange
gewitterfront ist quer über das land
gezogen heute nachmittag und aktuell
liegt der regen dieser front auch noch
bis hinauf an die ostsee die kräftigsten
gewitter entwicklungen die finden wir
aktuell aber im norden bayerns dann auch
mit hagel hier in weiß das geht in der
ersten nachthälfte jetzt auch erst
einmal so weiter dann aber zieht dieses
auslösende tief über die ostsee hinab
das größte unwetterpotenzial das
entwickelt sich dann morgen mit diesem
zweiten kleinen tief aber der reihe nach
wenn die gewitter nun im norden bayerns
in sich zusammengefallen sind steigen
dafür gegen morgen das gewitterrisiko im
westen des landes etwas an zum beispiel
in rheinland pfalz und diese gewitter
die beschäftigen uns dann auch morgen
vormittag noch hierüber der mitte des
landes ansonsten ist es aber erst mal
freundlich und trocken am vormittag
gegen nachmittag da gibt es dann aber
eine große gefahrenzone in einem breiten
streifen hierüber der mitte des landes
und vor was waren wir da nun das sind
zum einen starkregen mit über 40
millimetern in ganz kurzer zeit das kann
lokal zu überflutungen führen dann hagel
bruch durch große hagelkörner und
orkanböen sind in diesen gewittern und
auch tornados können wir nicht ganz
ausschließen das ganze beginnt am
nachmittag im westen des landes vor
allem in nordrhein westfalen gegen abend
geht es dann aber auch in sachsen
brandenburg und sachsen anhalt rund
passen sie auf sich auf